[Musique]
fiori je pense parce qu'il est
franchement il amadou bien et je pense
qu'ils mouraient mouraient à tirer avec
ces mots je suis trop sensible
mais comme je suis dedans je me faisais
vraiment sa jeunesse la mienne je
pourrais accepter ça dépend de la danse
je lancerai pas d'autre part et c'est
par contre un jive why not just sing et
sa partenaire
un mot d'ordre contexte dans le contexte
de ce métier je dirais ali parce que
dans mes doutes d'artistes et dans mes
dans les joies d'artistes même les gens
les plus proches de toi dans ta famille
dans tes amis vu qu'ils sont pas aisées
voulut pas dans le même contexte
émotionnel
parce qu'on est quand même
on vit quand même un truc à part est
extraordinaire donc ils trouvent des
alliés dans ce milieu dans ce métier des
gens qui comprennent à qui tu peux dire
les choses sans avoir à les expliquer
alors est elle bien cela personnelles
que j'ai avec qui je partage tout simple
[Musique]
philosophie c'est pourtant pas ma
préférée je pense que c'est la préférée
des gens qui donc comme je veux leur
faire plaisir je tisse devant chanté
qu'une tout le temps je chanterai
seulement bas depuis l'année dernière
enfin depuis deux ans je pars avec mes
amis lecteurs des [ __ ] je voulais
absolument que slimane soit là et il
sera là ça va aller l'année prochaine
donc je suis très heureuse je vous
dirais que c'est moi qui vais lui
proposer mien il faut bien choisir la
chanson parce qu'il faudra
[Musique]